صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد وزير
رئيس مجلس الوزراء في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو اصحاب
المعالي والسعاده السيدات والساده السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
لقد شرفني سياده رئيس الجمهوريه السيد عبد
المجيد تبون رئيس القمه العربيه بالقائك
كلمته الرئاسيه بمناسبه افتتاح الدوره
الثانيه والثلاثين لمجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه على مستوى القمه هذا نصها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسوله الكريم صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه السيد الامينه
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
السيد رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
السيد الامين العامل لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي السيدات والساده
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
اود في مستهل كلمه ان اتقدم بجزيل الشكر
وعظيم الامتنان لصاحب الجلاله خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولصاحب السمو الملكي ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
رئيس مجلس الوزراء على كرم الضيافه وحفاوه
الاستقبال
لقد تشرفت الجزائر باحتضان الدوره الواحده
والثلاثين للقمه العربيه في ظروف اقليميه
ودوليه بالغه التعقيد فضلا عن اندلاع
الازمه الاوكرانيه التي وضعت العالم في
حاله استقطاب متزايد وامام تحديات جديده
متمثله خاصه في الامن الغذائي والطاقوي
وفي هذا الصدد اجدد الدعوه لتعبئه الطاقات
التمويليه العربيه لا سيما صندوق النقد
العربي والصناديق العربيه القائمه لمساعده
الدول الاعضاء التي هي في امس الحاجه لهذه
المساعدات لتمكينها من تجاوز هذه الظروف
الدوليه العصيبه
على الصعيد العربي ستنظم الجزائر خلال
الشهر الجاري الندوه العلمي الاولى حول
الامن الغذائي في الوطن العربي بحضور كبار
الخبراء والمختصين العرب للخروج بمقترحات
علميه وعمليه ومشاريع ملموسه تمهيدا
لاعتمادها وتجسيدها بما يدعم الامن
الغذائي لشعوبنا اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو لقد وضعت الجزائر رئاسه اهل القمه
العربيه تحت شعار لم الشمل حيث بعد اعاده
توحيد الصف الفلسطيني في الجزائر الذي كلل
بتوقيع الاشقاء الفلسطينيين على اعلان
الجزائر والتزامهم
بالعمل على تجسيد الاستحقاقات المتضمنه
فيه نواصل التنسيق مع اخي فخامه الرئيس
محمود عباس
مساعينا راميه لاستكمال مسار المصالحه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه شعار لم الشمل تجسد
كذلك باستعاده سوريا الشقيقه مقعدها
الطبيعي في جامعه الدول العربيه بفضل
الجهود الدؤوب التي بذلت ومما يصفي عن هذه
العوده طابعا خاصا بالنسبه للشعب الجزائري
كونها تاتي تزامنا مع احياء الجزائر لذكرى
مجازر 8 ماي 45 واود ان ارحب عاليا
باسترجاع سوريا لمقعدها بين اشقائها مع
توجيه الشكر الى كل الدول العربيه الشقيقه
التي ساندت مسعى الجزائر وعلى راسها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو وفاء
لمسؤولياتنا التاريخيه اذا الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق وتجسيدا لمركزيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه في وجدان الشعب الجزائري فلقد
سخرت الجزائر
ديبلوماسيتها خدمه لقضيتنا المركزيه حيث
واصلنا المساعي على مستوى الامم المتحده
لحشد الدعم اللازم بغيه توسيع قاعده
الاعترافات الدوليه بدوله فلسطين
وحصولها على العضويه الكامله في منظمه
الامم المتحده وذلك بالتنسيق مع كافه
الاشقاء العرب كذلك
وبمناسبه الاحتفال باليوم العالم للتضامن
مع الشعب الفلسطيني طالبنا المجتمع الدولي
بتحمل مسؤولياته التاريخيه والسياسيه
والقانونيه والاخلاقيه والانسانيه تجاه
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق ليس فقط لوضع حد
لتعنت الاحتلال ورفضه الال الشرعيه
والقرارات الدوليه وانما لاتخاذ الاجراءات
الكفيله بوضع حد لسياسه الاستيطان التي
تمارسها سلطه الاحتلال كما ساهمت الجزائر
في الخطوات العمليه التي تم اتخاذها من
اجل اعتماد قرار الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده لتفعيل دور محكمه العدل الدوليه
من اجل تكريس حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني فضلا
عن توقيعها للائحه التي تمت المصادقه
عليها من قبل الجمعيه العامه المتحده حيال
قرار السلطه الاحتلال بفرض اجراءات عقابيه
على الشعب الفلسطيني وقيادته ومجتمعه
المدني وهذا بعد طلب الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده لرايين استشاري من محكمه العدل
الدوليه مع رفض الجزائر كل الاجراءات
العقابيه داعيه رفقه باقي الموقعيين الغاء
الفوري لهذه الاجراءات
من جانب اخر وتنفيذا لقرارات قمه الجزائر
ان عقد مؤتمر دعم القدس وتوج باعتماد جمله
من الاجراءات من شانها تعزيز صمود اهلنا
في القدس الشريف الذين يتعرضون يوميا الى
ممارسات اجراميه واستهداف حياتهم بالاضافه
الى القمع الاستيطاني الممنهج وسط صمت
دولي رهيب وعجز تام عن ضمان الحمايه
الدوليه للازمه للشعب الفلسطيني ومقدسته
لقد اقدمت سلطه الاحتلال على تصعيد خطير
تمثل في الغارات الجويه الغاشمه التي
شلتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه مخلفه العديد من الشهداء والجرحى من
بينهم اطفال ونساء عزا اننا ندين بشده هذه
الاعمال الاجراميه ونجدد تضامننا الكامل
والدائم مع الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق وندعو
المجتمع الدولي وخاصه مجلس الامن الدولي
لوقف هذه الاعتداءات الاجراميه المتكرره
والممنهجه وضمان الحمايه الدوليه للشعب
الفلسطيني وتمكينه من استرجاع حقوقه
المشروعه وعلى راسها اقامه دولته المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشريف وفقا لمبادره
السلام العربي التي اكدنا جميعا تمسكنا
بها في قمه الجزائر
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسموم لطالما دعت
الجزائر لاسيما خلال القمه العربيه
السابقه الى الاهتداء بفضائل الحوار
لتاسيس علاقات بناء مع دول الجوار الجيو
السياسي التي نتقاسم معها روابط الدين
والتاريخ والارث الحضاري فضلا عن العامل
الجغرافي وفي هذا الاطار نعرب عن ارتياحنا
لبوادر الانفراج التي حدثت من خلال
التقارب الحاصل في العلاقات العربيه مع
الجارتين التركيه وايران والذين توسم فيه
انفراجا في ازمات المنطقه واستقرارها وخفض
التوترات مما يفتح افاقا رحبا للتعاون
والشراكه ويمهد لاحلال السلام في المنطقه
وفي بعض الدول الاعضاء لا سيما في اليمن
الشقيق حيث نسمن كل الجهود المبذوله
لتسويه هذه الازمه بصفه نهائيه ورفع
المعاناه عن الشعب اليمني الشقيق كما نؤكد
على ضروره ضروره تعزيز التضامن مع اشقائنا
في الصومال وجيبوتي في مواجهه الجفاف الذي
تشهده منطقه القرن الافريقي العام السادس
على التوالي والتي تتطلب منا تدخلا عاجلا
لتفادي كارثه انسانيه محدقه بهذين الشعبين
الشقيقين وكافه الشعوب بالمنطقه
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسمو يشهد
السودان الشقيق انفجار دائره العنف
والاقتتال بين ابناء الشعب الواحد بعد ان
استبشرنا بالاتفاق الاطار الذي تم التوقيع
عليه لطي صفحه مرحله الانتقاليه وثوره
تدهور التدهور المتسارع للاوضاع على خلفيه
استمرار المواجهات المسلحه بين الاشقاء
السودانيين سارعت الجزائر بارسال رسائل
الى كل من الامين العام المتحده والرئيس
الحالي للاتحاد الافريقي رئيس جمهوريه
القمر المتحده والامينه التنفيذي للهيئه
الحكوميه للتنميه ايجاد من اجل تحرك سريع
لحقن الدماء والعوده الى المسار السلمي
لحل الازمه السودانيه العميقه بعيدا عن اي
تدخل خارجي في الشؤون الداخليه السودانيه
وندعو مجددا للاخوه الاشقاء في السودان
الى تغريب المصلحه العليا للوطن والاحتكام
الى فضائل الحوار لحل الخلافات وتجريب
الشعب السوداني الشقيق مخاطر الانزلاق في
الدوامه العنف الدموي الذي يشكل خطرا على
السلم الاجتماعي ووحده بلاد
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم لا يمكن
الحديث عن الاوضاع السائده في منطقتنا
العربيه بمعزل عما يشهده العالم من تحولات
عميقه وتطورات متسارعه تؤشر لظهور نظام
دولي جديد متعدد الاقطاب على انقاض نظام
نظام القطب الواحد ان هذا الوضع
بتعقيداته المتعدده
وبتداعياته الكبيره
يفرض علينا تعزيز التضامن والعمل كمجموعه
موحده تستنير بمبدا وحده المصير ليكون لنا
دور فعال وفاعل في تحديد توازنات الجديده
بالشكل الذي يضمن الحفاظ على مصالحنا
المشتركه ولنا من القدرات والامكانيات ما
يسمح لنا بتبؤ مكانه مكانه مرموقه
للمساهمه في رسم معالم مستقبل افضل
لشعوبنا
من هذا المنطلق وادراكا منا بحجم وطبيعه
التحديات الجسيمه التي تواجه الامه
العربيه وانطلاقا من ايماننا العميق
بفضائل واهميه العمل العربي المشتركه
المتجدد اود التاكيد مجددا على حتميه
اصلاح وعصرنه العمل العربي المشترك وفق
نهج جديد يتجاوز المقاربات التقليديه ليضع
في صلب اولوياته انشغلات وهموم المواطن
العربي واذ اعرب عن امتنان لدعمكم
للمقترحات التي تقدمنا بها من اجل تفعيل
دور جامعه الدول العربيه في الوقايه من
النزاعات وحلها وتعزيز مكانه الشباب
والابتكار في العمل العربي المشترك اشدد
على ضروره التجاوز هذا الاستعصاء الاصلاحي
والاسراع في تفعيل هذه العمليه الاصلاحيه
المحوريه لتمكيننا من مواجهه التحديات
المطروحه حاليا على المستويين الاقليمي
والدولي
في الختام لا يسعني الا ان اتوجه بخالص
التهاني وعظيم التقدير
[موسيقى]
لاخي صاحب الجلاله خادم الحرمين الشريفين
وكذلك لصاحب السمو الملك الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه بمناسبه
التواليه رئاسه الدوره الثانيه والثلاثين
للقمه العربيه
سائدا المولى عز وجل ان يمده بعونه
وتوفيقه في تحمل هذه المسؤوليه الساميه
ونحن على ثقه تامه بان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه ستقود بكل جداره واقتدار
اشغال مجلسنا لمعاهدناه منها ومن قيادتها
الحكيمه من حرص دائم على وحده الصف العربي
وتفعيل وتطوير اليات العمل العربي المشترك
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات